in Mesopotamia this is happening the
destruction of ancient treasures even
the leveling of entire cities by the
self named Allen nice Lamia I think the
reason this hurts us so much has
something to do with language we have
much older artifacts we even know of
older cities but the people of
Mesopotamia were the first to speak to
us on their own terms in their own words
whose words for starters Sumer fifty
five hundred years ago they spoken wrote
in amania Sumerian and isolate unrelated
to surrounding languages even when the
Acadians came in and took over twelve
hundred years later they kept Sumerian
civilization going Sumerian izing their
own words and culture as one linguist
puts it on a massive scale this
amazingly early cultural transmission
shaped ideas in the Middle East in
Europe at a time when most ancient
languages have to be hypothesized we
know what the Mesopotamians had to say
here this is a city they called it Eddy
do this is how much barley every child
and every adult should get 20 pints for
the kids 30 to 40 for the grown-ups this
is a story they wrote about a giant
flood the first documented semitic
language wasn't written in Phoenician or
the Hebrew alphabet it was in uniform
even the oldest indo-european texts were
written in cuneiform now I think
contrary to what's gone around on the
news cuneiform doesn't make Mesopotamia
everyone's cradle of civilization it's
hard to see what kind of impact Sumer
could have had on China and certainly
the kadal and the Olmec in the Americas
were a world away but it was this act of
writing early and extending its
influence to later ages that causes us
to connect with cuneiform civilizations
to hold them in such high regard and to
stand horrified at people who confronted
with that same influence feel not
respect
but hate
you